welcome everybody to another YouTube
hangout super excited to be back with my
friend the CEO of my favorite accounting
software giant sage sapphire Stephen
Kelly welcome back how you doing sir
gray Evan fantastic and we just did
ourselves a couple weeks ago and I came
on a road trip and I would have looked
you up in Toronto but literally would
just land it just did back-to-back
meetings then flew off to Boston so busy
we're well and I'm really excited about
this one
overcoming the fear of failure and I'm
sure we've all been there and had some
dark days so it would be really good to
get into the conversation I love it and
just as we're starting up you're showing
off some of your your new cuff links
yeah I think you got it you got a flash
it hey here you go Evan it's that time
here you look at this man there we go
it's festive time can you see that yeah
yeah yeah cool there's and the good news
is Santa everybody out there today on
the broadcast everyone is on Santa's
good list so we just did a broadcast for
all our colleagues and we got these kind
of silly elfs hats on and all that sort
of stuff it's like being in an elf move
you're not being a good actor so we had
all the fun you gotta send me one of
those hats and I'm drinking my knee and
my wife makes these smoothies and loves
these sage 15 or so every day every day
I get a little bit of sage in my life
here cool we've got a whole ton of
people watching us ready to go the Chad
is filling up like crazy we're talking
about how to overcome the fear of
failure we've got a ton of questions
already coming in but I want it before
before getting to that I wanted to get
the Stephen Kelly perspective I know you
always start with some quotes so people
love your quotes so will it lead us off
with some inspirational quotes so
there's some yeah this is something as
leaders who is challenged with so I kind
of get it and there's some great quotes
to kick off with the great man Franklin
D Roosevelt so the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself and then another one
from a genius inventor Thomas Edison I
have not felt I just found 10,000 ways
that won't work a brilliant inventor and
then an amazing sportsman but this
totally applies to business I've missed
more than 9,000 shots in my career I've
lost almost 300 games 26 times I've been
trusted to take the game-winning shot
and I missed I failed
over and over and over again in my life
and that is why I succeed Michael Jordan
and then our last one actually from
author said we've got a whole range of
people politicians inventors great
sports people some failure in life is
inevitable it's impossible to live
without failing at something unless you
live so cautiously that you might as
well not lived at all in which case you
fail by default Jake a round and hooray
Harry Potter and Evan amiright we when
we when we met at a little coffee bar
down deep in Toronto we talked about
these words you should have always avoid
when you have that kind of glass of beer
on a Friday evening if you've said these
words you may have let yourself down and
you let us down right if you say the
words could have should have or might
have you probably stepped into fear too
much to prevent yourself succeeding I
love it I love it well you're already
getting the the all-caps love all those
quotes and like the heart symbol and in
okay mark so people people are feeling
it it's great I love it man I look
forward to hearing what you have to say
every time before we get into the
questions at a high level
what's the Stephen Kelly perspective on
overcoming the fear of failure for
entrepreneurs yeah I think you know I
think this is a really great topic of
them because I think it's tougher now in
some respects so when I look at and you
love it and I love it I love social
media but sometimes let's be really
honest social media presents a world of
perfection and reality for business
owners entrepreneurs it is a
white-knuckle ride it's is daily you
know even hourly can be ups and downs
highs and lows you know moments of
incredible
to get your first daughter opening your
first door winning your first big
customer you know give another repeat
order all these things are moments in a
business of exuberance and yet we know
you know there's moments where you just
give you get like punched in the stomach
metaphorically and you just got to pick
yourself up and we talked about
mentoring and other other ways to do
that but it does take tremendous
resilience to be a successful business
owner and keep coming back and coming
back for more so I you know sometimes in
my career maybe we'll get onto this both
personally and professionally I felt
like I've been in the ring with a sort
of heavyweight box and I get chucked out
the ring you dust yourself down you get
back on the canvas you know you take
punches you're down on the canvas again
you lift yourself up and sometimes you
know that could all happen in a week but
my philosophy is if you believe you
believe in your idea you know you want
to be your own boss you know what your
passion is be true to yourself stick to
that because it will come good it will
come good and you just have to really
believe in it's everything you espouse
Devin in terms of hashtag belief stick
at it court correct it and you'll come
through and we'll talk about maybe ways
of handling and overcoming your fear of
failure but ultimately you have to
realize I think and keep in mind that
mountain and putting the flag on top of
the mountain because when you do have
tough days in the foothills you need to
dust yourself off and there's always
forces in your head the great fear and
reasons not to do it and you've got to
be a leader who makes it happen so for
the entrepreneur who's got that great
idea but maybe they'll doesn't have the
environment around them maybe they don't
have supportive parents maybe you know
supportive friends maybe didn't go to
school for it you know they have these
moments of boldness for they're all
excited like I can do this and then they
wake up the next day it's like well who
are you to do that you've never done
that before you know you're gonna lose
everything you're gonna risk your house
what what are some of the four that
dreamer who wants to go and do it and
they want to over come into the like the
the how to's
tactics what would you recommend because
things a lot of entrepreneurs we're
watching that who are going through that
now but they want to play a bigger game
right they're too afraid to do it so you
have a vision but they're too afraid to
take that action
what what what tips would you give them
I think you have to look at yourself
Evan and I think you have to ask are you
the sort of person who gets mental
strength from insight and if you have a
burning idea you know I've known many
entrepreneurs who actually are quite
introvert and they're brilliant but they
have incredible mental strength
incredible belief they believe in their
idea and they find huge resilience I've
found other people and I probably fall
in this category who need peer group
support and I think it's very easy the
case at yep and you'll find lots of
people particularly if you young you'll
find lots of older people telling you
why your idea is not going to be a great
idea and they'll tell you all the
reasons for failure and you can listen
to them and if that's the case you give
them you know due respect but what you
need to do is find a peer group who
inspires you who lifts you up who
creates wind beneath your wings and just
gives you the sort of emotional
spiritual and the support to say
actually you can have a go at this and
then you probably don't want to bet the
farm on the idea initially so think
about what we're talking about before
how could I test drive stuff how could I
prototype stuff how could I even go to
my friends and see if an idea is gonna
run and if ultimately you know every one
of your friends and your family come
back and say you're the craziest guy on
the planet
you should reflect and if you still feel
you believe about your idea after that
you need to go and find and surround
yourself with people who really give you
positive energy because I think actually
the power of positive energy we all know
this and it's almost if you believe you
can if you believe you can't you're
absolutely right that can be hugely
uplifted so I was your experience ever
I love us that's one of my favorite
Henry Ford quotes if you leave you can
you believe you can't you're right I
love it
I agree I mean the environment matters I
extended to to think about not only the
people in your life but the the media
you consume the resources like right now
everybody who's watching this live chat
you know you have you have mean Steven
as you peer group you know we want to
answer your questions that's really
filling up with tons of questions but
what what videos do you watch on a
regular basis what books are you reading
a regular basis you know a lot of people
say I'm from a small city and there's
nobody here doing what I want to do and
I don't want to move to a big city you
know just coming up with all the excuses
where you can find people online you can
learn from videos and books and other
resources make that a part of your daily
habit so that you're putting the right
things in your head that support that
bigger vision for what you're trying to
do surgery I have one of the guys you
and I respected and we had him at Sage
summit in Chicago up on the stage there
God Richard Branson obviously a rockstar
entrepreneur you know started with what
500 pounds and one of the biggest brands
on the planet now and let me read some
of the companies you've probably never
heard about so virgin Cola virgin
clothes virgin fish and virgin vodka for
my I'm virgin jeans virgin brides why
why aren't we heard of because they all
failed so they're you know that's
probably one of the world's most famous
entrepreneurs one of the most successful
people on the planet
awesome awesome guy but he has practiced
you know overcoming that fear of failure
achieving the impossible you know he
wants to do commercial flights in space
and stuff like that so he's way out
there's you know in the Elon Musk sphere
of opportunity and dreams but you know
day to day he's launched a load of
businesses that never came to market and
just didn't work out so I think there's
just so many overwhelming reasons where
you can look around a peer group who
have experienced failure and who can
give you emotional and mental sort of
resilience and support and get you to
reconnect with your dream and your idea
and your passion and with a plan to
execute it you can be successful hello
sure here's some questions people are
anxious yeah all right
I love it yeah let's go that's good
Stephen is the people's CEO this one was
our most voted on question in the in the
pre-chat people should have early racing
to get their questions in comes from
Sebastian are you doing the right thing
if you need motivation for what you're
doing
that's a great question do you know and
I think the answer is always yes I kind
of think it's almost like and by the way
ever and I think you're the world's
favorite broadcaster that's that's the
world's favorite broadcaster that's you
you know you're way ahead of people like
James Corden the stuff like that who's
an import I just think what I need to
say here is it's almost like you need to
feed your inner self and I could think
of analogies or obviously around
nutrition for health exercise for
fitness and well-being but I do think
you need to as an entrepreneur and
business owner you need to create some
people who will give you positivity and
people who give you sort of challenge
I'm really good critical constructive
input and it allows you to refine your
ideas and loads of ideas and I've done
this you know we came up with an idea in
the 1990s and when we actually launched
on the market it look materially
different from what our original idea
was because we listened to people we
listened to customers they gave us great
input we never could imagine how
customers would have wanted to consume
our product and that allowed us to
improve it so I do think it's important
to get motivation because I do think you
need to feed positivity optimism and
also feed your idea because otherwise I
think you could lose the will to pursue
your dream so I definitely I would I
would be an advocate of motivation
positivity and I do kind of see it as a
almost like a food you need to be
consuming there's an entrepreneur yeah I
agree I think we are
of doubt I don't think there's anybody
who never doubts themselves and always
you know is is fearless 100% of the time
you need that in your life what I would
what I would examine Sebastian is if you
are how many time of the motives like
why do you want to do this why is this
business so important to you whatever
this thing is that you're trying to do
why does it mean so much to you and if
it comes down to that you don't you
don't love it anymore or we're going to
just try to make the money then then the
motivation won't help you you know then
it's time to move on and do something
else you can get all fired up by but I
think like for me I'm it's it's a daily
thing I wake up and I need to use my
morning routine to get me fired up for
the day right put on the music do the do
the exercise in the morning and you know
like that I have my morning routine that
gets me all set up and I need to do that
every day because I kind of I have a
great talk with Stephen Kelly guys I'm
gonna like fire it up for the rest of
the the afternoon I'm gonna wake up the
next day and I like start from scratch
again and so I need that consistently in
my schedule but I think if you find that
you don't love what you're doing anymore
then it's time to move on to find
something else Stephen what's here you
have a crazy morning routine you're up
and like you're running and yeah I love
trying to particularly I've done a lot
of traveling we did these kickoffs
around see all our colleagues so we did
like one week damage and it's Berg from
London to Pretoria
up to Paris the next day on the Tuesday
I think then we went down to Madrid
Wednesday up to a place in the north of
England you car so and then Friday we
finished up in Frankfurt so I'll be
honest it is full-on it's intense is
like from five o'clock in the morning to
or probably midnight and if I don't try
and on most of these things if again
sometimes it's just not possible where
if I get up and do my even a 20 30
minute run on that one it was great fun
actually because we invited the video
loads of things through the Sage
Foundation which is the charitable Armus
age and we got we did challenge all our
colleagues to chase and beat the CEO so
they all came out you know down
to Johannesburg we went on a run
together with a load of colleagues Paris
was all mind blown I got up like some
crazy time like five o'clock and outside
the hotel it must be 30 40 colleagues
and lens of these guys amazing what
sacrifice for them getting up even an
arrow they're coming in from the suburbs
but we ran from this hotel probably
about five cats quite long way up here
up to amazing church called sacre coeur
which on top of the hill in in paris and
you were overlooking the whole of Paris
asam the Sun started rising and it's
magical you know about why do I do it it
give it lifts me it gives me energy and
there's loads of physical evidence about
endorphins and all this sort of stuff so
it is good and I just think actually
Evan and I think probably one of my sort
of self criticisms I don't know where
there's a CD or a I'm pretty sort of
extreme I love a routine you know I kind
of like a routine so the same routine
sort of helps me get into the zone of
coming in the office have an energy you
know tackling good days and bad days
really some days good some days a less
good but it gives me a good start of the
day so and I think you know if you start
the day well then it's a great start to
the week and literally it gets you off
to right place and and if you do you
know if you've had a weekend it's funny
when you have weekends because you kind
of replace about holidays vacations
let's talk about this just a completely
thing that came into my mind
loads of people on vacation will think
you know reassess and priority' store I
really want to do this I've been at this
business two years and I'm really going
to break through is it all too hard I'm
hit sitting here drinking tequila
slammers in some exotic resort in Hawaii
you know and and little voices are find
on vacation really get into or you can
kind of turn it and say actually it's a
great time to reflect and some things
I'm doing the business work in terms of
my idea but some of them I could do
differently and some people come back
from vacation she
yuuji energized but also being able to
reflect from the outside in on what
wasn't going well and then come back
straight in with the energy to fix it so
it is a good time to if you can do that
and I know loads of people do things
like honestly mindfulness meditation I
think you know I applaud those people
because it just gives you the space to
think and reflect on what's working well
and what's not and you know to reconnect
with your passion so I love that any
ever do you do any of those things to
help you get in the zone so for
vacations
I hate beach vacations I could do maybe
like half a day at the beach and then
I'm out then I'm then I'm I gotta go see
the city or I'm looking at the
restaurant thinking how could this
business be better or you know analyzing
the people selling the the floats and
anyway it's like I I I need the
stimulation in terms of a morning
routine though I wake up like I watch
the videos on my channel I made the
channel selfishly for myself
the famous entrepreneurs that we profile
works for myself because I wanted to be
around these great thinkers and have
some of their minds that kind of seep
into me and it was a selfish pursuit
that I shared with others and they're
enjoying it as well and I find that I
need that on a rig look at my wall like
I walk into this room every day right we
got people that I look up to and I
learned from on my wall here and it's
all part I think everybody needs to
design an environment and a schedule
that gets them fired up you know like
you may not know who this guy is or
those people are like it doesn't matter
they mean something to me like copy mine
and put it up on your wall find the
people that inspire you I have these
people looking at me when I walk into
the office it gets me fired up to go and
do the thing that I want to do and kind
of think a little bit bigger and get out
of the comfort zone so now you're you're
travelling in your different city every
time we talk and you know but for those
of you who are not jet sitting around
the world you know you can do something
in your home office right just have
something up on the wall that means
something to you make it special for you
just I think it's great what you do Evan
I think why I would encourage us all to
do is kind of reconnect us with our
dream and whether it's pictures or
imagery or prose you know to connect us
with why we started our business and
what our big idea could do to change the
world and if you come and see that every
day I think that gives you power next up
is Marvel talking about New Year's
resolution so that's that's timely here
he's he said it's trying to change his
approach this year to focus on not
making a list of resolutions of making a
list of mistakes and explanations to
look at why he's not why he didn't
follow through on making those plans and
fixing the mistakes from last year what
are what are our thoughts and how do you
go about making resolutions or even do
you for the new year do you know for the
new year I'm gonna try one thing of it
because I'm so conscious I bust my chops
I'll be honest I demand a lot from
myself I never think when I look at
myself I've done well enough and that's
good a deeply ingrained in my psyche I
think and this is advice I'd give to
everybody when you look at yourselves
we've got great people today join us for
the blab I think I'm gonna try in the
New Year to say not for me but for other
people just look for the good things
they did and it's almost back to it
sports you know if you do competing
against karna validates like Usain Bolt
for the hundred meters do you beat
yourself up all the time on that 100th
of a second where you don't come out the
blocks or do you celebrate the things
that you do well in the last 50 meters
where you accelerate away from everybody
else in the field I think we should are
most leaders focus way more on the
things we do well and make them even
better and if we do that I think we'll
find we let's make miss let's make make
less mistakes and also any sort of
improvements we need you could call them
whatever you want really
we've all got weaknesses but you if you
accentuate the positives if you
accentuate and if you've got people
working for you in your businesses if
you just give them a bit of phrase about
what efforts they put into achieving
something though
was connected to your big passion and
dream and idea then wow you you'll make
them rise 40,000 foot and fly out of
your home office and they'll be able to
rule the world and I think so often when
I look at it and I'd say this for myself
in terms of want to learning for me it's
so easy to you know say oh you did this
okay but I want to tell you about these
three things that you didn't do so good
and and the voice in your head because a
lot of overcoming the fear is smashing
down the walls and smashing those voices
that tell you you can't do stuff because
you know you can you know you can and if
you keep on listening to the voices
around your in your head
they'll just grind you down and and you
can lose the will to live so I do think
actually both for yourself it's really
good to celebrate the positive save at
the moment but most of all you got you
know you're a company of two three five
people wouldn't it be powerful when
you've won a big order to take everybody
out for dinner and just celebrate that
enjoy and say your contribution was this
and if we hadn't won that you know maybe
a pitch or it may be the product they
invented or whatever is so powerful to
galvanize the people together against
your passion for your dream and I think
so if one thing I do is in terms of the
New Year's resolution yeah okay spent
maybe twenty percent your time when you
do that on the one mistake but actually
spend eighty percent your time on the
things you did really really well and
then you become a super trained athlete
to do them ever better and you know
focus on the positive yeah for to
Stevens Point I would encourage you to
not just wait till the new year's
resolution to come around to start doing
it like if Steven inspired you with that
story about celebrating the win then
today is the resolution like do it right
now so many people waiting to the
negative start something and then and
then they fall off track a couple weeks
in I would love for you guys listening
and watching for entrepreneurs so when
you get an idea just go out and and try
it like even even if you don't know all
the details right so I want to celebrate
I'll win okay great is it gonna be at a
restaurant is it gonna be what the gift
certificate or we're gonna like you
start getting you started planning all
the things out the perfectionist and
that's planned all the things that we
make it some big thing and then because
it's so big we never do it because
that's to be the perfect thing and we
never do anything and I think just
starting something small it could be a
phone call look you get someone taking
somebody out it could be just buying
them a Starbucks whatever just try
something see how it feels and adjust
and I would love for you guys to get in
the habit of constantly doing a
self-evaluation and checking yourself
and not waiting until New Year's or your
birthday or some other arbitrary day
like just start doing you get inspired
by something here today take action I
mean that would be both Stephen and
myself insanely happy that's the goal
right don't wait another you know a
couple weeks do something today yeah I
think evident as well that's such a
great point and you know another great
quote never leave till tomorrow what
could be done today and I think yeah one
way to the New Year if this is a great
holiday season and for you guys who have
got customers out there and if you got
you know people working for you
colleagues the work for you and follow
your dream what a golden time to say a
really heartfelt thank you in the
holiday season is sort of a time to
pause reflect they're gonna go home with
their families or you know friends and
it's a really a pretty cool time to pick
up the phone to customers send them a
SMS or a direct message just saying you
know thank you so much for your customer
over this year I'm really excited about
working with you again in 2017 so this a
great time just with the not just the
new year for the end of the year just to
celebrate what you've achieved this year
you know recognize a few of the people
like especially your customers and the
people who have built that which is the
people you employ and just say thank you
very much it's a good time and and now I
think everybody wants to feel valued and
the more you do that again it is it's
kind of where there's this our flywheel
of positivity because if you say that to
your colleagues and you say that to
customer they're feeling the love for
your big idea and
they'll give you great feedback I love
it
next up is Kathleen Tate now Kathleen I
remember Kathleen she attended sage
summit she came to my session and then
when I was leaving she drove me to the
airport so she's a hardcore fan from
Chicago she writes in to say my fear is
that I'm a social worker attempting to
get into the fashion world
I get motivation from Evans channel and
I was booked through one word of advice
I'm moving from a part-time entrepreneur
to a full-time entrepreneur yeah hey
Kathleen I'm sorry I didn't give you a
ride to the airport but Evan Almighty he
rocked in Chicago he said the Windy City
alive and you know I think some context
around that I I think we really have an
opportunity here in social work wow what
a great what a great job you do you know
without you the world would be just a
lesser place and people who do social
work form a communities should be valued
by everybody and you know creates great
social cohesion we've talked before
about caring for the vulnerable so you
walk it every day now I think if you
want to get into things like fashion
designer fashion actually you've got a
great platform in terms of your current
job what are there for Kate you do is
again you know you've got a big dream it
could be around fashion and we love that
you you get inspired by Evan which is
brilliant but you have got the platform
where I hate to use that word but you
could kind of moonlight doing your
current job while you're getting income
from being a social worker but use that
and use the time at weekends and
evenings to start creating your big idea
and you've probably you know gonna have
a website associate of that products and
design and and maybe even start talking
to potential customers and potential
sort of distributors and stuff right
there and even potential manufacture so
you could what would be a really cool
idea like this via Kathy and you got a
promise you're gonna do this we're gonna
do another
broadcast in a year's time and you're
gonna come on the channel and say Evan
I'm now running a designer fashion
business with a million dollar turnover
and I did it because of that broadcast
gave me the inspiration and I spent six
months still being a social worker but
actually that gave me the platform to
build even if it's a few hundred
thousand dollars you know that would be
unbelievable and totally amazing so I'd
kind of say you know straight with all
these things kind of cut the elephant
down into little chunks you got a great
hopefully secure income being a social
worker use it as a platform do an
amazing job as a social worker do some
moonlight in the evenings and weekends
to say how am I going to use this
platform to connect me with my dreams my
passion which is all about fashion and
then build that business go after it
build the business you know fund it
sensibly just to kind of kick it off get
get some product sales then reinvest
that in growth and then you'll find
you've got a business you love and
inertia the only tough decision you've
got is when do you stop being the social
worker and give you a notice really and
I would advocate that you kind of jump
off the diving board once you've got
your business and a bit of momentum and
you believe in it then then you should
go now the other thing right I've got
this great piece of advice from someone
Wow when I went off to it was a startup
company at the time it was a company
called Oracle technology company
everybody knows them you know about the
time nobody knew there were a No Name
company and they were a start-up and I
was with a pretty safe company at the
time and I went to my boss and said a
lot they've got this our offer from
Oracle they sound like a pretty crazy
American company gonna rule the world
big vision they got this guy Larry
Ellison running them and and he and I
said I really am torn because I've got a
great career here pretty saved earlier
but I think I would want to risk it
early-stage company and he said the good
thing is to him and he said if you leave
and resign you know the doors always
open if you leave well and you never
burned your bridges so actually there
should be no fear of
your decision because your world might
your trust did you do a great job for us
but most of all you should go and try
there and if it worked out you're gonna
be a Rainmaker somewhere else but if it
didn't work out the door's always you
know open here and and the only thing
that you might have to you know swallow
is your pride but you're a big guy
you're a grown-up that will be no
problem for you good advice so so
Kathleen I love 2017 to be the year
where you make it happen a new follow
your dreams and you're an incredible
brand in terms of designer fashion
that'd be amazing I like the one year
challenge to get to a million I love
that and what did you say but elephant
cutting it into chunks how is that
explained yeah hey L they say this like
they say let's bring the moose in the
room yeah in Canada we say over in
Europe let's get the elephant on the
table but how do you eat an elephant
you'd cut it into very small chunks yeah
break it into two thousand chunks so
when you put a business plan together
and you're gonna be the biggest design a
fashion brand on the planet Kathleen
you're gonna break it into little chunks
what do I want to do for now 90 days
hundred eighty days you know and then
you'll find momentum you'll find you'll
have a following you'll find you'll have
raving fanatics as customers and you'll
develop partners and you're hopefully
all your employees would be brand
ambassadors for you and then you got
Rolling Thunder you've got momentum but
you have to kind of start small have a
massive dream big dream and just a
phrase I use yeah cut the elephant up in
a thousand junks and then you can eat it
and enjoy it eat the elephant one chunk
at a time all right I like that for
people who are part-time kind of move
full-time I agree with Stephen I would
say you need to make sure that you are
spending time every day on your business
it's easy to get caught up in your job
and responsibilities if you have kids
and you know life can get in the way and
then you never actually do the thing
that is also supposedly important to you
which is your business so make sure
you're spending time on every single day
even if it's half an hour like every day
something to help your business grow and
then try to figure out what where your
skills are best used what's the highest
value that Kathleen can bring because
people will throw all sorts of ideas and
you like Kathleen you got to get on
YouTube Kathleen you got to be on
Instagram Kathleen you got to talk to
this manufacturer kept clean you know
you got to go to these presentations
whatever it is and you end up doing
everything in a mediocre way instead of
you know one thing really really right
so what's what's the highest use of
Kathleen's time that you can apply in
those 30 to 60 to 90 to 120 minutes a
day to really make them count
you figure that out and then you're on
your way to going from part-time to
full-time and Beyond hi Kathleen by the
way ever and I you know we're pretty
humble guys and we're really happy to do
product placements for really cool
designer clothes that you're gonna um
create over the next year or so so we
would be pretty cool to come on
you know heavens flap and you know I
guess everyone would love to wear a blue
jay shirt or designer clothes created
and brilliantly inspired and nurtured by
Kathleen so so we'll do product
placement soya and we'll pump and the
other day actually if you get go in and
you follow your dreams I love I love
what I love doing is pumping out great
ideas from I'm so on social media so
well we'll give you all the help you can
that's some love and if anybody's making
cuff links out there I might even just
wear a collared shirt with with the cuff
links the kids would love these hey the
kids would love it is they're gonna love
them like on on December 25th thinking I
love it's Christmas early I love it okay
next this is this is from a sage
employee a sage employee writing in on
the live chat trying to get some advice
racy for the for the corporate
entrepreneurs here
what they do is the name what they do as
a self-proclaimed entrepreneur how does
wine successfully develop a position
for themselves within an organization
that best utilizes their skillset I'm a
sage employee and then that's great
actually and what fair hopefully you
know the sort of culture we have Evan in
here is totally informal meritocracy you
know on that that world tour we I met
10,000 colleagues in four weeks I spoke
individually to loads of people you know
we do loads of fireside chats for me and
the executives to remain connected so we
want to we want to create a culture of
great innovation and connect directly
with customer and put ourselves and live
in their shoes and we believe you know
which all about these the business
builders who are on the broadcast today
and on the blab and these guys you know
this you guys have dreams passion energy
you probably funding businesses from
your family or friends
you work unbelievably hard you make big
sacrifices you live on a kind of
rollercoaster ride of highs and lows and
I don't think there's any more noble
cause than what you guys are doing out
there so it's very special and also I
should mention you guys create 70% of
the jobs in Canada the u.s. so well you
provide huge social cohesion in urban
and rural communities and create jobs
and prosperity apprenticeships I could
go on but we think you guys deserve
awesome technology so that's where we
fit in both so warfare you what you
could do and there's some examples of
this there's an amazing leader we we've
got crush armor and she's actually
innovated all our stuff around chat box
that we provided the first chat bot on
the counted engine so you can sit here
in things like Facebook Messenger and
just literally have a human conversation
with your accountant engine posting
invoices and you could take photograph
of a receipt if you take a client out to
lunch and then automatically post
through and kritis done that she's
almost a credit to start-up within Sage
so we really encourage our colleagues to
innovate stuff
and now Critias running a product
division around sort of artificial
intelligence and really cool stuff and
we'll have lots more chat BOTS coming
out because ultimately our our belief
you know and if we don't do if someone's
going to create this so it might as well
be us because we're the good guys is
around zero admin zero admin for
entrepreneurs zero admin so we have a
dream that you guys will spend all your
time just running your businesses
growing your businesses employ more
people being more successful and we live
in a world where you know today probably
out of there at least two or three years
ago some of you folks on a Sunday
afternoon had to kind of you know get on
word processor stuff Google Apps and
start typing out invoices to your
customers or something and it was really
horrible manual or you go along to your
accountant at the end of the year with a
shoebox of invoices and receipts and
everything has to be keyed in again the
world of the future is all kind of
frictionless this kind of well we've
come to expect as consumers and so
therefore the promise we do create I
think and it will happen is a world
where zero admin you'll have real-time
information on everything in your
business cash flow you forward all the
book whether you need more cash to fund
your growth in the future and and that's
the mission we're on so you know what
failure I don't think I've ever been in
a business where I'm more excited about
the people we're serving because the the
our level of entrepreneurship out there
blows me away and I'm inspired by
meeting the 22 year olds 24 year olds
you know all the Millennials with
massive dreams with actually fewer
inhibitions than we ever had and a
really clear sense of purpose and great
values in terms of building their
businesses and you know I think the
world of technology is going to
revolutionize how fast they can grow
their businesses and we've already sort
of seen that with the mega companies
like you but some Facebook's they
created companies that in 5 10 15 years
that would have taken you know hundred
years to build in the last
century and ice killing just get faster
and that's why I think the opportunity
for you as entrepreneurs on the blab
today is is almost limitless and it
really is about just the basics of
having an idea pursuing your passions
and then finding the team around you and
the customers and the way to market to
actually allow you to fuel your dreams
and really really pursue at a more rapid
rate than ever before so Wharf a you
know why I am actually everybody knows
where I am I I tend to answer my own
emails I'd tend to most of the time do
my own Twitter and social media so and
we're all approachable I think everyone
would say as well everybody sort of
laughs just support entrepreneurs so
whether you're an internal entrepreneur
entrepreneur or external then you know
it's great news and actually as loads of
people back to Kathleen's question who
would be so proud of people having a
full time job
and during that full time job they'll
they'll start a new venture and they'll
go off and create something really
really special and magical with their
idea and I think that's you know
something we should all cherish very
cool well Kathleen wrote back to say oMG
all in caps thank you this is awesome
followed by eight exclamation points so
appreciating the advice there for Faye I
would say the advice that comes to mind
is Mitt Romney who said in a speech that
we covered the secret to getting ahead
is doing your current job really well
and especially when you're in a
meritocracy if you are doing an amazing
job you know if you're in a company like
sage you're doing an amazing job you're
gonna get recognized you're gonna get
notice you're getting a plucked and you
know be offered for greater things I
also think you're really fortunate that
you work for Sage where almost everybody
has Twitter and is on social and is
posting stuff as in part of Stephens
plan is getting all of his team on
Twitter and so you were lucky because a
lot of senior execs are not on Twitter
in most companies I'd be following all
of these other senior execs seriously
then just like
you probably followed Stephen you saw us
on here you're joining and you're asking
the question see what your bosses are up
to and just be a resource try to help
out answer a question share something
you know post it away just be involved
in their pet projects and you're gonna
get notice as well but you still got to
do the work you got to be a hard worker
and then put in the little bonus extra
effort on the side too
that's cool whatever Luke okay Luke has
been asking this question at least 10
times in the chat Luke I'm hearing you
there's a ton of questions we're gonna
we're gonna get it this is for you Luke
okay Luke says I'm a young entrepreneur
and people keep telling me or giving me
the feeling that I won't be successful
what advice do you have
Wow Luke attach it safe summit one
things that blew me away I went on the
floor and we did laser mentoring I met a
14-year old entrepreneur on his second
business idea I loved it it blew me away
God so Luke I don't know what age you
are but um there's so many people and
maybe maybe this is maybe it's a little
bit ageist but particularly some older
people who probably will tell you the
reasons why it's not such a good idea
but if you believe in it and then you
know do everything we've talked about
previous programs good test your idea
test drive it ro test it you can road
test it with your friends you can ro
test it on social and you can create
following and that will give you the
energy and positivity to know that your
ideas gonna land but I how do you know
if an idea is not going to land if you
don't try it and and back to that
example if you don't try it you know
failure is that she not trying it the
fear of failure actually creates almost
like a cancer you fail to try it then
you know you've you've let us all down
because you could have done I'd tell you
ever naltar Leah today if you have an
idea you know if you back yourself
you're halfway there and and what what
is brilliant on what I love to
more than anything is defying the cynics
loads of people to be cynical or jealous
people might be jealous that you've had
that idea and you're gonna make your
idea come to reality and you're gonna
make your dreams come true
but you know I'd back yourself and I'd
do you idea whatever happened you know
and it's amazing it you never know what
twists and turns life's go in front of
you so I'll give you example when I left
graduate school AHA and it was before
the internet so I wrote one of my
buddies they give you an example a real
good buddy corporal Smith great guy he
wrote two hundred and forty companies
two hundred and forty companies and he
only got a handful of replies all of
those turned him down he didn't even get
an interview but he kept on going and
just you know could you're much now
demoralized that I got turned down by so
many companies for graduate school
I even got turned down this you know I
applied to all these great companies at
the time called Unilever and all these
great P&G and they turned me down so
what are they funny thing this Evan you
know you in those days you kind of did
these placements I did a four year
course and I did kind of - they call it
a sandwich course a placement of the
company and the company that I did a
place from that VP I thought I was a
shoo-in for the job I went for the job
and I got turned down how does that work
so but you just got to pick yourself up
and and what I would I would say there's
a few things in that sort of scenario
one of the things I asked for which is
so powerful that I don't think very few
people asked for is a magic word called
feedback and if people turn you down you
know whether it's for an audition if you
want to be an actor whether it's a
business person you did a pitch or if
you're gonna you know a later stage
company if you're gonna raise money and
you do a pitch to your family you know
why are they back you're why they turn
you down if they if they if you ask them
for feedback it is mind-blowing how you
can improve your business your product
your whole sales picture website your
social experience so I think you know
bottom line Luke is you know back
yourself defy the cynics try your idea
and constantly have those social aunt
and I are to say you know how can I
constantly improve and course correct my
product and my idea to make it land and
make it big I love it and Luke is loving
that that we picked this question so
he's he's happy in the chat Luke I would
say I would say one back to our initial
comment at the top about the environment
the environment matters I would start
surrounding myself with with young
entrepreneurs who are off trying to do
something and if you don't have any
other entrepreneurs that you know go to
meetups go to events try to try to
connect with them and if you still can't
find them then you know read articles
watch videos like learn from people are
already doing it so that you know that
it's possible I think Mark Zuckerberg
big success made it possible for a lot
of young entrepreneurs because hey if he
can do it I can do it too I'm gonna I'm
gonna bet on myself and then the second
thing I would think about is the people
who are giving you the advice and maybe
because they're jealous and maybe
because they love you
like maybe mom and dad love you and they
just don't want to see you fail they're
not trying to hurt you they think
they're trying to help you I would look
at how the people who are giving you
this advice done it before have they
done it themselves
and if they haven't then they may not be
in the best position like the people
were hating on you if they haven't done
it themselves they haven't taken a
chance themselves maybe they're not the
best people to kind of be giving you
that advice I wouldn't pay attention to
them right and find out seek out the
mentors who you can learn from getting a
ton of chatter here Sam is saying in all
caps please do not end this Evan
don't let Stephen log off so cool
Fanning Sam Sam thank you thank you Sam
yeah well we're only here to serve you
guys and it's a real honor and it's a
privilege for us to have you guys tuned
in and we just hope you helped you if
one of you guys
feels the conviction to overcome any
fears that you have and from today you
start living your dreams well you know
everything we do is worthwhile Luke
right in boxing thank you I love the
answer
Georgina is asking what Stephens Twitter
account it's just as Kelly CEOs carry
handles see skc yeah Gina you follow me
I'll follow you back there you go there
you go and how much you how much you
tweet in a day depends from on the road
or tweet more but on average probably
about three or four tweets sometimes
definitely the end of the day at the end
of this night Friday I look back enough
tweeted quite a law posted a lot on
social media and I think you know maybe
I'm a bit too noisy so I need to be a
bit more selective but I get quite
excited oh I'm quite exuberant guys so
you know if I see something amazing I
just post it or I hear of stuff that's
amazing I just post stuff so but I love
it
I want to keep the conversation going so
yeah definitely Georgina follow us and
I'll call you back
very cool well there's there's still a
ton of questions I think we have time
for maybe one more
Kenard is saying do you think just
because I'm shy I can't make it Canaris
obviously shy do you know Akana I think
I said this and I think lots of great
entrepreneurs are introverts I think you
know shy as a relative term isn't it
because I've known really shy people who
have come in to become a business owner
and they've been hugely successful and
as time goes by and they grow in
confidence their shyness sort of
disappears I think you never you never
ever get carried away with your own PR
you always keep your feet on the ground
you always keep that great sense of
humility and you really want to you know
you want to be true to your idea and the
purpose that you pursue it so I think
can I they honestly I think I think in
this area honest can be quite a virtue
and I think with all these things is is
if you are feeling to take
actually another another example you
know when you go up to these kind of
meetups and stuff like that
even I will tell you now I go and do
loads of talks and stuff like that if
someone comes over to talk to me I will
always talk to them so if you're at a
meet-up and you want to kind of Zone in
on one person get voice in your head
saying that person wants to meet me
today walk up to them and just introduce
yourself and you lose nothing even if
you're gonna never see that person again
you lose nothing but every time you do
that you lose a bit of your showing us
and you've gained a bit more confidence
and I would advocate all the great
entrepreneurs you and I follow they're
all super nice guys they really are nice
guys and gals and fundamentally they all
started where you're probably starting
today and the good guys never forget
where they came from you know it's
reality we never forget where we came
from we all started as aspiring
entrepreneurs with a dream with an idea
and an ambition and some of us kind of
got lucky and the cards played in our
favor but we never ever ever you know
reality lost that sense of shyness and I
think you know everyone he looks like an
amazing extrovert but again I'm sure in
his past have moments of shyness or
lacking in confidence I certainly did
I've been to places where I've been
afraid to go up and introduce myself to
someone and sometimes it's sort of
either a little friend on my shoulder or
or someone in my inner self just kicks
me to say go and introduce yourself
don't don't feel any any shame just go
up and overcome and then the more you do
it the more you practice the more
confident you become and you know can I
you might be the next you know Tony
Robbins or something like that within
you all these guys who go and do TED
talks and all these sort of things if
you look back at those guys 10 20 30
years ago they all started as someone
who's pretty shy someone who probably
lack confidence and any of those people
could be you I love it what a man
which to end on I love it guys thank you
so much for joining us today we're gonna
kick it up again in January we'd love to
know what topics you want us to talk
about we're happy to go anywhere you
want to take us let us know in the
comments not the live chat because You
Tube deletes that immediately after
after it goes on the channel leave in
the comments below what you want us to
talk about next and we'll do that
Stephen thank you for the time man I
hope you have an amazing holiday season
yeah well I hope everybody else out
there has an incredible holiday we
actually did a little Christmas holiday
message so holiday message the Americans
the European sort of Christmas but you
should go on on YouTube I shall post a
link afterwards it's just like 53
seconds it all it does is celebrate the
amazing business builders around the
world and the sacrifice they make so in
that spirit you know thanks guys for
joining us we love doing these Evans one
of my inspirations and he's sharing the
love of belief and confidence for the
business builders you guys out there so
it's a real privilege for me to join
Evan on these and and thanks for your
great questions and I wish you all are
really happy holiday and see you back in
the New Year I love a thank you guys
continue to believe and we'll see you in
January
take it